[Musique]
allez venez de gaspard là bas c'est une
scène cruciale parce que je défie
l'ennemi on va dire publiquement en
allant faire un gros un gros concert
sauvage pas du tout prévu devant ça
devant sa prison à lewaï figuration les
arrive comme des zombies ces démarcheurs
dans les danses étaient disposés avec la
scène en eau de même les bras qu'ils ont
utilisée pour filmer aussi c'était
quelque chose d'impressionnant commun y
voyant le 1er rep a poussé la machinerie
dont tel groupe va commencer à être en
mouvement
[Applaudissements]
c'était lourd c'était lors de faire un
concert dans une prison dehors et que le
monde qui avait la foule des figurants
c'était c'était vraiment l'eau et la
presta de atik et avoir filmé en donne
comme si je faisais un vrai concert
comme si je faisais mon vrai concert
parce que c'est moi qui écris leçon
tu parles arrive aussi ses coûts lui
sauver l'otage a tout particulièrement
apprécié ce moment parce qu'il faut
savoir que dans tous les figurants il y
avait beaucoup de mecs de nos quartiers
c'est une fierté pouvoir partager ça
avec eux impressionnant en plus on a
repris vie libre en prison c'est quelque
chose
actuellement on est à la prison de
fleury mérogis dans une aile désaffectée
de l'ancien centre des jeunes
délinquants de fleury mérogis
je me rappelle très bien que l'équipe
arrive le matin comme tous les matins
depuis hier que d'un coup on se rend
compte qu'on est l'arrêt puis ça crée
une ambiance un peu particulière sans
m'être dit si un vol d'oiseaux il ya des
mecs qui sont en cellule des fois de
plus 20 piges je viens de mac tyer donc
un des rappeurs qui joue son propre rôle
dans la série qui tourne sa scène aux
parloirs à fleury mérogis et qui quand
il a réussi au tournage m'a tout de
suite dit j'étais dans cette cellule là
pendant trois ans une création originale
à découvrir en avant-première en ce
moment sur my canal